vous pouvez prendre votre visage à la pelle pour que
le soleil ne brille pas
[Musique]
nous avons tous des droits souverains et nous sommes
juste ici pour lui montrer que chaque
fois qu'il y a une crise, le gouvernement l'
utilise pour renforcer son autorité  et
essayez de vous retirer vos droits juste
parce qu'il y a une crise
ne perdez pas vos droits sinon vous n'en avez
jamais vraiment eu pour commencer nous devons
envoyer un message clair c'est le meilleur domaine dont
ils ont besoin pour rouvrir notre économie en ce
moment les gens vont tomber malades  et c'est
malheureux et je n'essaie pas de
minimiser la maladie c'est juste que
malheureusement des gens meurent c'est ce qu'on appelle
vivre nous allons tous nous n'allons pas
nous en sortir vivants
que je reste à la maison ou que je sorte tu peux
toujours mourir quoi qu'il arrive  tu fais donc je
ne suis pas accro à l'adrénaline mais je ne
veux pas qu'on me dise de rester à la maison maintenant j'ai
un système immunitaire je prends ma muta pour ça
et c'est tout je ne suis pas garanti
demain quoi qu'il arrive j'ai trois
entreprises  et je sais qu'ils sont fermés en
ce moment parce qu'ils  'ne sont pas essentiels
Je retarde tout mon personnel Je ne sais pas
si mon entreprise survivra pour ouvrir dans
deux semaines en perdant nos droits constitutionnels
et nous tombons sous une dictature
et ce n'est pas correct
[Musique]
les chiffres sont faux vous avez  vous savez qu'il y
a 1% de chances que cela meure
un pourcentage plus élevé de teinture d'
autre chose, mais c'est la vie, vous savez que
nous ne pouvons pas continuer à vivre dans la peur chaque
fois que vous montez dans la voiture pour aller travailler,
vous avez une chance d'acheter et chaque  la fois où
vous allez marcher devant votre porte d'entrée vous
avez une chance de mourir vous ne pouvez pas vivre
votre vie à l'abri parce que vous avez
peur de quelque chose
[Musique] le
gouverneur de la Sicile est responsable de l'
arrêt de l'économie au Nevada période
où l'économie basée sur le tourisme et  il l'a
effectivement fermé en mettant au
moins un Nevada sur dix au
chômage c'est inacceptable qui dit que le
communisme ou le socialisme ou le fascisme nous
ne sommes pas une société totalitaire nous sommes une
république constitutionnelle le peuple
au lieu du gouvernement f  rom les gens
maintenant on me prend mon argent
parce qu'ils veulent envoyer aux gens douze
cents dollars par personne un valet
[Musique]
J'ai des amis et des voisins connaissent ces
entreprises ils meurent ils meurent
il y a beaucoup d'entreprises qui vont
ne pas être en mesure de rouvrir les
gens sans emploi les gens qui restent au
chômage les gens qui perdent leurs
économies à cause de ça
[Musique]
Je pense que le gouvernement a dépassé les étapes, nous
avons des droits ont une
responsabilité personnelle pour l'analogie ils n'ont pas
besoin qu'ils nous disent comment  faites-le, je
pense que c'est juste si louche que nous ne puissions pas
faire ces choix pour nous-mêmes
[Musique]
la seule façon de faire démarrer une Amérique et le
Minnesota est de nous permettre et de
retourner au travail et plus longtemps
nous resterons en dehors de  travailler, plus
vous aurez de suicides et plus
les êtres humains en bonne santé seront réellement